it's so interesting jimmy because i i
truly am a fan i've always been a fan of
the producer i love the behind the
scenes person
and you continue to astonish me
with stuff that you've done that i
either forgot or didn't know that you
did and a couple of months i was out
here on march i was at a restaurant in
l.a and i was listening to just be good
to me by the sos band you know what's
funny about
just be good to me by the sos band
and i just i literally was back i did a
show for um
abc um where they interviewed um
different people
and they literally
where they filmed it was at sunset sound
in the room that prince used to record
in at sunset sound and i realized i
hadn't been to sunset sound since the
day prince fired us
were you in that same room uh 1983. wow
we had gone for a session and you know
we thought we were going to start
recording
and we had already set up a session to
mix just be good to me at a different
studio on that very same evening
and of course we said well we'll go see
prince you know we'll we'll do that and
prince fires us we go in this little
room uh right off a studio i think it's
studio three that he used to record in
and uh he just goes you guys produce the
sos band i told you not to produce other
groups so you're fired
and so so terry and i walked out
and we kind of looked at each other and
we were like what do you want to do and
he said
well i guess we'll go to that other
studio and mix the sos band record so we
walked into the studio
uh the engineer was a guy named steve
hodge yeah and so we walk into the
studio larabee sound is what it was
called and we said oh hey steve he says
hey nice to meet you guys we said nice
to meet you he said what's wrong you
guys seem kind of down and we said
yeah we just got fired from the time and
he said really we said yeah
and he said well
he said i don't think you guys have
anything to worry about because this
song here
this is a smash this is a slapper he
pressed play and that
came on with that steve hodge mix coming
out those big speakers
and we were like whoo okay so i mean it
was very much a hollywood ending or what
you'd call a hollywood i mean you
couldn't even write that script yeah um
but being back at sunset sound and
sitting at that board that we had sat
with prince at that same board it's all
looks exactly the same it's all the same
thing that was just a few weeks ago or
maybe a month ago that we we did that it
was amazing was that the last time he
ever spoke to prince did he ever or did
years go by and he's like oh i see what
you guys became oh no no no we no we had
a great relationship um
he fired us as terry likes to say he
freed us right i think he pushed us out
the nest he knew
he knew he said you guys are going to be
okay